- Wait, speaking of strip,
you went to my show.
- [Matt] Yes, I did.
- I was like, you said you were gonna come
and then I didn't know if
you really would, you did.
- Oh, no, I was on top of it.
I bought tickets to your
last show of the residency.
- [Kelly] That was a fun one.
- Because I knew that was the one
that was really gonna give.
I was like, they were all gonna give,
but I was like, I know
that you're gonna whip out the classics.
Is that me sobbing at your show?
- Is that the one?
Wait, is that the one that
I did "Happier Than Ever?"
Is that the?
- You did "Happier Than Ever."
You did "Sober."
- Yeah.
That's for real fans.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then you did, I didn't know this,
but, so I had, of course,
memorized the set list
before we got, by the way,
I brought like 13, 14 of my friends.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm not kidding, we went
as a Gay Army to your show.
(Kelly laughs)
So, we went and I had like
memorized the set list
and I knew at the end
when you were gonna stop
before the encore.
So I was like, I can go to the bathroom.
At this theater, the men's
room was in Timbuktu.
I'm going, and I hear just,
♪ What if I told you ♪
And I'm like, she's not
doing "A Moment Like This."
She had never done "A Moment
Like This" in the show
- I never do "A Moment Like This."
- [Guest] Really?
- She surprised did "A Moment Like This."
I peed faster and harder.
(audience laughs)
- And then you were running.
- And I was sprinting back.
And also it's like you're pretty,
let's say hydrated when you're in Vegas.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- There was a lot of stuff that was drunk,
so I had to go so bad, but I was like,
let me make it back for
"A Moment Like This."
And then I got there and I sobbed.
- I love the video.
No, you're so..
- [Matt] I was really
crying hard.
- [Guest] I mean, anytime you sing, I cry.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, I never, I never sing
that one generally just,
yeah.
- Yeah, I know,
and that's why I was so
surprised you were doing it,
because I know you traditionally don't.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so then I was like, come on,
I'm literally at the urinal
screaming to my friend
Patrick, "We have to go!
"We're not washing our hands!"
Like it was, I will
cop to being unhygienic
when it comes to getting
back to the seats.
- [Kelly] Oh, if I'm running
back in somewhere, yes.
- Yeah, no, it's just.
- Or it's usually my kid at a movie.
They're like, "I've gotta pee."
Are you serious?
- I know, but you put on
such an incredible show.
I mean, obviously it was you guys,
you are adding new shows, right?
- We are.
That's announced, right?
Yes, yes.
(audience clapping)
Yes.
We are.
We did, we added a couple, I think.
But I'm always like, what
am I allowed to talk about?
I always forget.